die deutsche einheit ist ein prozess der
noch nicht abgeschlossen ist so steht es
im jahresbericht der bundesregierung
der bericht verweist 30 jahre nach der
wiedervereinigung auf viel fortschritt
aber auch auf weiterhin große
unterschiede zwischen ost und west
einwohner in den neuen bundesländern
liegen beim einkommen immer noch bei 0
86 prozent des westniveaus
allerdings haben erstmals die
einkommensstärksten ostländer das
schwächste westland überholt außerdem
kompensieren laut dem bericht die
vergleichsweise günstigen preise für
mieten und bauland in den neuen ländern
den rückstand beim verfügbaren einkommen
zu einem erheblichen teil bei der
wirtschaftskraft klafft die schere noch
weit auseinander
das bruttoinlandsprodukt pro einwohner
liegt in den ostdeutschen bundesländern
bei knapp 73 prozent des gesamtdeutschen
durchschnitt berlin nicht eingerechnet
seit 1990 hat sich die wirtschaftskraft
im osten jedoch vervierfacht dass sie
noch nicht der des westens entspricht
erklärt der bericht mit strukturellen
faktoren etwa der geringeren
siedlungsdichte und dem mangel an
konzernzentralen und großen
mittelständischen unternehmen
so ist auch die beschäftigungsquote in
den neuen bundesländern geringer
allerdings liegen männer und frauen dort
auf fast gleichem niveau
während in den alten bundesländern ein
unterschied von rund 8 prozentpunkten
zwischen den geschlechtern besteht dazu
kommen auch rein demografische
unterschiede menschen in den neuen
bundesländern sind deutlich seltener
verheiratet und öfter alleinerziehend
und ostdeutsche männer haben eine
geringere lebenserwartung sie sterben
statistisch gesehen etwas mehr als ein
jahr früher im vergleich zu männern in
den alten bundesländern bei der
geburtenrate liegen ost und west nach
erheblichen schwankungen seit 1990 nun
fast gleichauf
der bericht macht klar dass noch viel zu
tun sei lobt aber auch die große und
auch erfolgreiche kraftanstrengung die
bürgerinnen und bürger des vereinten
deutschlands und ihre institutionen
vollbracht haben